en temps normal vous auriez toutes les
chances de croiser rostislav au pub avec
des amis le dimanche après midi mais
aujourd'hui il apprend plutôt les
rudiments de la manipulation des armes
j'aurais aimé ne jamais avoir à
apprendre dit il mais dans la situation
actuelle c'est ce qui doit être fait
vous être prêt à tout ils sont
aujourd'hui une trentaine comme lui des
ingénieurs des informaticiens des
professeurs l'entraînement ne dure que
quelques heures ça n'en fera pas des
soldats concèdent leur instructeur mais
ça vaut quand même le coup
[Applaudissements]
sur mille personnes que j'entraîne
seulement 10 prennent les armes pour
thierry ne serait ce qu'un seul russie
dit dennis alors mon travail n'est pas
en vain pendant qu'ils apprennent à
ramper à se retourner enclenché leur
arme à l'étagé maria elle se charge des
médicaments qui seront envoyés aux
soldats au front
il ya beaucoup de médicaments qu'on ne
trouve pas en ukraine on n'a plus rien
dans les pharmacies les antibiotiques et
les antidouleurs on en a pu nous en
ukraine dit elle
avant la guerre cet entrepôt servait à
l'import export d'alcool et de fromage
aujourd'hui c'est le point d'arrivée de
tous les dons qui arrivent de partout en
europe
anton était au sommet du mont
kilimandjaro quand il a appris que la
guerre éclatait dans son plein il est
rentré sans attendre le guide
touristique 4e qui les plus hauts
sommets du monde pour des montagnes de
vêtements chauds de nourriture et de
couvertures son père est russe itar au
stop sur le donne c'est le plus dur ne
croit pas à la guerre en ukraine
personne dans sa famille en russie ne le
croit non non
non mike bibby a fait non
non j'en vois des vidéos ils disent
encore non
les dents ce n'est pas ce qui manque
mais encore faut-il pouvoir les
acheminer et c'est là que ça se
complique marina est responsable de la
distribution des médicaments et de
fournitures tantôt soldats qu'aux
hôpitaux dans les zones de combat il
faut agir très vite dit elle
hier nous avions préparé des palettes
pour les envoyer dans un village et
comme le camion se rendait sur place le
village a été détruit
ils doivent emprunter les mêmes routes
que celle où les civils qui cherchent à
fuir risqué leur vie pour une deuxième
journée consécutive le cessez le feu
promis ne s'est jamais matérialisée
pin quelque 25 kilomètres au nord ouest
de kiev une tentative d'évacuation a
tourné au drame au moins trois personnes
des enfants ont été tués par les tirs de
mortiers russe alors qu'il cherchait
comme eux à quitter leur ville il ya de
quoi payer loudiadis vos potées je sais
qu'il ya des gens qui ont vraiment
besoin de quitter qui ne peuvent plus
rester nous avons entendu les promesses
de corridors humanitaires
mais ce sont des corridors de sang qui
nous donne a dénoncé le président et
minsky en soirée à mario paul tout était
en place matin les autobus patienter aux
abords de la ville encerclée sans eau
sans électricité et chauffage depuis
quatre jours les russes nous ont menti
accuse le maire de la ville juste
facebook
youtube
les tirs n'ont pas cessé depuis six
jours depuis six jours dit il ces 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 de
circonstance est insupportable vous ne
pouvez pas imaginer la cruauté
une cruauté qui semble à des
années-lumière du calme relatif de lviv
on devine à peine la guerre qui fait
rage en ukraine tandis que kiev est le
coeur du pays que le vivent et son âme
il en va de même pour l'effort de guerre
si kiev est au coeur des combats le
vivent et y envoie toute son âme au
front
pendant conquis dans la chapelle ici ou
sous sol on s'assure que les soldats ne
manque de rien ces femmes préparent des
rations jouerie nuit dans chaque boîte
un dessin d'enfant et d'autres petit
réconfort
des cigarettes bien entendu c'est un
anti stress dit oksana alors beaucoup de
cigarettes c'est un devoir pour elles
est la complice avec le sourire
quelqu'un doit le faire alors pourquoi
pas nous
dans la pièce à côté des dizaines de
bénévoles tissent des filets de
camouflage pour les soldats lydia vient
presque tous les jours avec sa famille
c'est ce que je dois faire pour aider
les gens pour aider ceux qui meurent
pour moi pour ma famille pour les autres
alors les combattants ne sont pas seuls
à se battre nous aussi on se bat ici
c'est simple filet semble bien peu pour
protéger les soldats qui affrontent
l'armée russe au fond ce qu'il tisse ici
c'est peut-être autre chose qu'un moyen
de défense contre l'ennemi avec chaque
maille ils fabriquent aussi la fibre
d'une nation fière et solidaire ici
marie ève bédard radio-canada le vivent